[Music]
hey everybody it's the matinee show
episode 59 three new movies either on
streaming service or in the theaters we
did two in the theaters and one on
Netflix this week yeah so let's talk
about the Netflix one first this is a
little movie called assimilate yeah this
is kind of like I guess this has been on
Netflix since maybe last May or June or
something like that and I just now got
around to watching it um it's a sci-fi
horror I guess I would call it almost
kind of like an old-school monster movie
it was yeah um it it seems like it's
been getting like really kind of shitty
reviews um you know it's got like an
average of like less than five not
percent but less than five out of ten so
I mean I didn't know that before I
watched it I just kind of watched it cuz
it was new and I'm not saying this is
like a fantastic movie but I'm just
saying I don't really know why
everyone's [ __ ] on it so much I mean
it's clearly low budget I will say from
the outset that it is pretty much an
uncredited remake of invasion of the
Body Snatchers except done with like
more teenager college-age type
characters yeah so if you're familiar
with that story then this will not be
all that surprising because it's very
very similar you know what I mean I
think they even had like some of the
same pods and stuff they it's it's kind
of like engendered a little bit
differently it's basically about there's
these two guys at the beginning Isis
they're high school seniors or whatever
they're best friends and they have like
a web series or they're starting a web
series and they're documenting their
boring little town which i think is
called Moulton Missouri and their whole
joke is like nothing exciting ever
happens there but they're documenting
like real small-town American life or
whatever so while they're doing this web
series and the kind of going around
filming everything and it's not really a
found footage movie it does have aspects
of that because some of the you know
some of the stuff is from their footage
but it's not like I wouldn't call it a
found footage movie so as they're kind
of documenting all the people in town
who are all like really normal and
everything like that then someone that
they know like one of their neighbors
who they all have a crush on she's like
an older but like um
I guess that they all have a crush on
when they like check out her ass when
she's like out gardening or whatever and
she gets attacked by something that they
don't quite see they think it's a rat
and it leaves this big like cut on her
thigh and then they've chased the rat
through the woods and like then the
town's preacher like looks like he puts
the rat in a box and then like they get
back in the car and then the preacher
starts acting really weird and then so
like everyone in town starts acting
really weird and so them and this girl
that that one guy has a crush on who
notices that her dad is also acting
really weird they kind of have to band
together and figure out what's going on
cuz like the cop doesn't believe them
and like some people are getting you
know assimilated title drop but as I
said it's you know it's clearly
low-budget the CGI isn't fantastic in
some of the parts but it was actually
much better than I was expecting
even though cuz I didn't really know
anything about it like going in it's
just other than like the couple of
sentences they give you on Netflix so I
didn't know that this was gonna be like
invasion of the Body Snatchers which is
essentially what it is but you know once
I kind of figured that out and just kind
of relaxed and enjoyed it it was a
perfectly fine enjoyable movie it's
probably not something you'd watch like
more than once or you know anything like
that or that you'd recommend or that
you'd even like remember a few weeks
from now but you know for yeah there was
nothing wrong yeah if you have 90
minutes to kill and you like kind of
like alien pods taking over like a small
town joke that it has like a little bit
of twist ending naked people naked
people yeah although I'm not sure it's
naked people you'd want to see yeah it's
just it's just it's just a b-movie yeah
you know I mean back in the 80s it would
have been for you it would have been
done in real corny yeah they've been you
know along the lines of something like I
don't know Halloween three prints how I
would have come out come out like that
bro yeah probably
today they can make even a crappy movie
look pretty good yeah I mean I thought
this looks pretty I mean it looked
better than like a sci-fi original
that's yeah sure like the CGI looks
better than that yeah I would say I
think it's actually kind of just
kind of above-average yeah from what's
going on there's nothing there's no
reason to get mad at it yeah it's like
that's why I couldn't figure out it's
like I guess I can figure out why the
reviews are kind of like middling or a
lot of people hated it and stuff like
that but it doesn't seem like something
that would really like inspire that kind
of hatred because it's just like a
perfect fine just normal movie it's just
a normal maybe maybe maybe people's
standards are too high it's like they
have to nitpick every single only [ __ ]
they saw the [ __ ] of they saw the [ __ ]
on Netflix it's not like they you know
they were they just pay the subscription
yeah they're at home they'd have to go
any that's it I mean it's like you
didn't have to go to the theater and pay
like 16 dollars so watch it and I'm a
double sign it's like movie overload
nowadays there's so many movies out
there that people are getting real
[ __ ] picky I can understand it on say
like you know 150 million dollar movie
like term like the new Terminator but on
these low-budget movies they're just
entertainment yeah and as long as they
can keep me entertained their entire
runtime as long as they don't bore me or
you know yeah or pissed me off or
anything like that
at home you got a drink in your hand
you're watching this [ __ ] yeah it's like
that's all you gonna be yeah everything
so you know it's like I know it doesn't
sound like I really recommend it but
it's like if this is kind of your kind
of thing like invasion of the Body
Snatchers but with a younger 90% of that
[ __ ] on [ __ ] Netflix 90% of [ __ ] in
the theaters is just that that's what I
mean you just watching it and I think
that it's been like that like forever
ever leave arrows rewrap yeah you go see
a movie and you're like wow that was
[ __ ] great yeah most movies like yeah
I was pretty good you know that was I
didn't feel like I wasted my time you
know what I mean the only thing that's
supposed to be mind-blowing really are
big tentpole movies they spent a lot of
money on that you know I mean those are
supposed to blow you away
at least visually you know or some kind
of a damn art film that can blow you
away yeah you know I mean didn't need a
big budget like Joker yeah no budget
it's just past a billion dollars today
yeah even that lighthouse one that at
least I had a reaction to that yeah yeah
well and like I said and we've talked
about this before it's like I really
like when you see a movie that you can
tell was just like one or a small group
of people's like vision yeah and they
didn't care if it was gonna be popular
they didn't care if like a bunch of
people's they just really really wanted
make it like Eraserhead yeah and they
got all their [ __ ] together made it
that's why I really really liked the
lighthouse because it was just so weird
and it's like he didn't care like if it
was gonna be off-putting for like for
some people or anything like that but
you know again most movies you know
eighty eighty-five percent of movies are
ones like this one where it's just kind
of like it's good enough it's
entertaining like when you watch it but
you know you're not gonna like remember
called what am i anything like oh man
you gotta see this it's so it's not like
that but I felt I didn't feel like I
wasted my time it wasn't perfectly and
just not like I had bad acting it wasn't
you know it wasn't you know like some
from Ed Wood productions or anything you
know well those can also be edited with
movies just kind of boring to me well
I'm a lot of driving shots love why
can't a lot in the 50s because I mean if
you see a lot of the movies that from
the 50s that they did on MST it's like
you can tell that they had like a little
pinch of story and it would only bit
have been like 10 minutes if they filmed
that so they had to Pat out another set
lots of dudes in suits sitting in
offices talking and talking bones to
other dudes and other offices yeah
there's like usually like a long
conversation and it's like what you know
like one room that they redress to look
like several other offices like just for
a change of scenery yeah that's the same
room yes I feel like a lot of movies in
the 50s had that because it's like well
they started out particularly low-budget
ones you started out with like a great
concept and a great poster and they're
like okay write a movie around that and
it's like you can only afford to show
the giant spider
you know for a couple of minutes because
you know you didn't have the budget so
grasshoppers on a postcard [ __ ] people
like sitting around in the office
talking about how they were being
official and scientists the scientists
say that or walking around yeah there
was a lot of that that the heart is
nothing but one single big cell remember
that remember that yeah that was from
amazing colossal man what the [ __ ] a
heart is not a cell they thought it was
yeah one big cell the scientists have
said that I was like yeah so you know if
you have Netflix and like I said you
like kind of b-movie sci-fi type stuff
and you have 90 minutes to kill then you
could certainly do worse than watching
assimilate
so I'm gonna check it out she's gonna
tear it up huh
pokey
you
all right second movie we saw this week
we finally got around to saying cuz it's
been out a couple weeks hasn't it
Terminator dark fate yeah so this one I
hadn't read really any reviews of or
anything like that I heard that it
wasn't doing like it's made a lot of
money but it hasn't made as much as they
expected it to and it hasn't like I
guess it hasn't made its production and
marketing budget back so they were gonna
do like a whole new trilogy and stuff
but I guess they're not gonna do that
now because it you know was
disappointing box office so you know
going into it with that and going into
it with you know I have to say like I
love the first Terminator Terminator 2 I
loved it at the time but rewatching it
recently I still like it
except for Everett for a long as
annoying as [ __ ] he threatens to like
drag home if he teleport there's a lot
of problems in Terminator 2 that a lot
of people don't want to see cuz they
just have a lot of nostalgia for that
movie I liked parts of that of
Terminator 2
I did too I liked everything except yeah
for that kid
but there were problems with the movie
yeah what makes terminator is Arnold
Schwarzenegger as a villain and that
only happened in t1 yeah because he
didn't really like playing villains
today was something his contracts yeah
really he wasn't gonna do it anymore
after that yeah he made such a good
villain now it's like villains didn't
get killed and then the yeah just like
what they said in that Hollywood movie
once that you see the guy get killed
over and over forever and also do you
suppose yeah that eventually happen um
yeah
Terminator 1 really the Terminator story
is best told in Terminator 1 well yeah I
don't think anyone you don't need
terminator to terminate Terminator 2
we're not talking about Terminator 2
right no no I don't want to get into the
leather daddy aspects and a little boy
in the back of the motorcycle type
family there's a lot of [ __ ] kind of
crazy [ __ ] in [ __ ] dad I was going to
say was that I'm kind of coming at it
with the first one was like awesome
obviously yeah the second one like I
liked it at the time and I like a lot of
things about it but you know there's
some stuff that I don't like about it in
hindsight um I didn't see
let's see I didn't see three I don't
think which was the one with Christian
Bale and it was at the Alsatian war that
was four I don't know there I saw that
one I have a mall and I get like that
one was okay but I didn't see Terminator
Genisys or anything like that so I'm not
like maybe not as invested in the
Terminator thing like I you know I kind
of wanted to see it kind of not I like I
knew I was kind of ambivalent about
saying it um I will say that as much as
people seem to be complaining about it
um I liked this one better than
salvation um and I liked some of it I
liked aspects of it more than the second
one yeah it's not a bad movie it's a
very good action movie action set pieces
are very good it's long but it moves
along at a good clip like you never get
bored or you have to look at this movie
as a standalone though it's almost it's
almost like not of Terminator movie to
me the only Terminator movie is
Terminator 1 yeah it's a low-budget dark
horror sci-fi action movie almost kind
of like Friday the 13th yeah except it's
you know with Jason except it's a it's a
it's a robot yeah and it's Arnold and
it's Arnold and being [ __ ]
intimidating and that's really what made
that move is a low-budget movie you
don't see much about the future you're
just on a blue filter you know what I
mean and then some robots and run tanks
and really the the less you talk about
the future and the more you keep that a
mystery the more power the Terminator
has when you when you start having
Skynet talking and then it just it just
sucks all the mystery out of it yeah and
yeah we were talking about that a little
bit more it's like sometimes that's why
and it's like yes I understand why like
if the movie is successful yes they want
more of that place so there's like they
just want to keep making sequels but the
problem is it's like they're never gonna
be as good because you have to you know
kind of demystify a lot of the mythology
about and that's what made the first
movie so good it was and you just have
to like keep elaborating and elaborating
and try to do something different every
time and you keep just keep getting
diminishing returns yeah and I think
that's what happened in this situation
even though like I said I like this
one probably the best of all the other
sequels that I've seen I can understand
why some people were mad and I'm not
gonna I mean I know it's been out a
couple weeks but I don't want to like
spoil all the big plot points even
though one of them happens like in the
first five or ten minutes in the movie
the one that seems to be pissing
everyone off the most but I can
understand why they did that just
because they didn't want to do the same
[ __ ] I mean this is the sixth Terminator
movie it's all creative decisions but
when you start doing all these creative
decisions to not make it like the other
Terminator movies eventually you don't
have a Terminator movie anymore
yeah Terminator theme standalone action
movie and to me that's what this seems
like yeah I can future saying yeah none
I mean yeah if you were to give me a
hundred fifty million dollars and say
make a Terminator movie alright
out of out of gone with [ __ ] instead of
a continuation I just gonna thrown
everything away and redone Terminator
one yeah a higher standard with somebody
say like The Rock as The Terminator
yeah somebody you know something like
that yeah and maybe added a little bit
to it to where you could make another
Terminator after that maybe like two
more if they want they want trilogies
but yes is that what made Terminator
great with such a simple premise yeah
you're not gonna be able to make three
movies out of that and especially once
you get into when your whole franchise
is based around time-travel which means
and it almost seems like like an under I
can understand from a writer's point of
view like you're like oh I can do
anything because we can just go back in
time and [ __ ] this and say it's an
alternate timeline and all this other
kind of [ __ ] but I feel like you should
probably refrain from doing that because
you're just allow your elaborating so
much that like the [ __ ] that there's no
continuity or anything like that because
when you have time-travel like I said
you can essentially do anything because
you can just say that oh will somebody
went back and monkeyed with this and now
it's different you know what what made
terminator great is is that it was a
movie of its time you're talking about
the 80s the early part of the 80s and
they're imagining a robot from the
future from something the internet
Skynet is the [ __ ] Internet it's
exactly what they were talking about
swear they got the idea because in those
days the internet was just something the
middle
he was talking about yeah they at the
time they made that story they had no
idea that everybody would have the
internet on their phone and the phone
would be in their back pocket the phones
also the TV and the computer and the
movies yeah and the rest of the world
that that that concept was just so far
ahead of us back then you know he could
have done it yeah so the whole premise
that made the whole premise of the
Terminator really is as a child of the
80s if you start doing it now and put it
into modern term it doesn't make any
sense because if something from the
future comes back here it's not gonna be
humanoid robots it's gonna be something
like nanites that fly around like dust
and you breathe them in they kill you so
you would think that would be maybe some
super super efficient high tech that
wouldn't be scary wouldn't look good on
film so for me terminator always has to
be happening in the 80s yeah and it's
actually kind of a good point because
it's like why the [ __ ] yeah well I mean
when you think about it why would like a
super intelligent AI from the future
like why would they go to all the
trouble of building all these robot yeah
they wouldn't kill people I mean but
like I said back then we didn't know
like about nanotechnology which would
obviously be much much super viruses
they would have just put a virus in
there and it seems like just wipe aside
I guess you can spray down spray down
some you know genetically engineered
chemicals that only kill humans you know
no man you put him up to satellites and
sprays it down and kills everybody on
the planet there's a bunch of different
ways you don't need humanoid robots to
that's what I mean a supervillain this
is the idea of the 80s but it's a dumb
idea about a today's fight yeah now that
we know what we know right and I think
maybe that might be part of the reason
why most of the subsequent Terminator
movies have been less and less
successful yeah because because as we're
getting closer to where that technology
is possible right you know the the kind
of the cracks and the premise begin to
become a lot more yeah and then they're
talking about well though earth was
destroyed by a nuclear explosion - that
that happened man the weapons the weapon
of mass destruction of the futures have
basically just swarms of miniature
drones the size of pennies that land on
your head and blow up yeah and they look
for people based on
what they look like yeah
facial-recognition and they're
controlled by a damn AI program that
would that would run those damn humanoid
terminators into the ground system like
that and we're almost able we can
basically do that now yeah we could do
that now I'm a technology so go I mean
I'm gonna say going back to terminator
dark fate like I said they you know they
had high hopes for this because they got
Arnold back think I'll let Hamilton back
they got James Cameron back you know
they have the dude that Tim Miller who
directed Deadpool he was the one
directing it so you know and he got you
know James James Cameron went gotta love
input from novelists and stuff like that
he's like you know what would you do
it's like you know we want to do this
then the other thing and what he ended
up doing and I can see why he did this
it's like he almost went back to the
original premise because it's still this
has something to do with a woman who you
know will do something in the future a
horrible Terminator is set back to kill
her and another in this case it's not
she's not a terminator she's like a an
Augmented human being comes back to
protect her and they kind of meet up
with you know Sarah Connor and then they
have to fight against this Terminator
which can't be destroyed and you know
they kind of hook up with Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's character who was a
terminator and then there's like an
alternate timeline like I said I don't
want to spoil that so they're kind of
just like all fighting against that so
it's kind of like a similar plot to the
first one but in a way that they have to
like acknowledge what came before but
also kind of like do something else with
it so it's kind of like they had a
thankless task and I can see what they
were trying to do with it
like I said the tones the tones was kind
of cross the board too because you're
supposed to take this thing seriously in
some areas and other areas it's kind of
light-hearted comedy they do weird [ __ ]
with ducking with Karl The Terminator
the new was leader of the resistance
it's like what a 411 411 4 foot 11 tall
girl you know I mean yeah it's just and
I thought I thought the idea of John
Connor being a leader of the rebellion
was ridiculous because he had no real
leadership qualities you know well I
thought yeah that was
a problem that was a big problem to look
at this kid you go he's the leader of
the rebellion it's like a [ __ ] you
know the one grabbing that man around
him around his waist on the back of damn
leather daddy motorcycle gone he's
leader determined was floppy hair you
know no man yeah I had a girlfriend look
just like that boy same here yeah yeah
the thing I didn't like about about his
character was that that movie I had
forgotten it's so painfully painfully
90s and just all the slang that he was
using and like the attitude yeah it was
like oh it was like this horrible like
Disney Channel shows like from back in
the 90s where all the teenagers were
like or that all the preteens were all
like wisecracking like that yeah so so
this might be altogether like I said I
didn't have any expectations for it
really going in other than I knew it
hadn't been doing as well as as they
expected and I knew a lot of people had
been bitching about it um but that said
like I said it was a perfectly enjoyable
movie like it was totally fine I
would've been a lot better if I struck
yeah I wasn't bored at any point I felt
like the humor fell a little flat
yeah um some of the CGI was a little
ropey yeah but the action set-pieces
were generally good the acting was
generally pretty good the girl that
played that played grace the the
augmented human she was really good yeah
it was funny is that she had that damn
Dylan roof haircut looked like Dylan
roof like the white suburbs this haircut
[ __ ] yeah I thought that that character
was gonna be ridiculous but actually she
was the best character in the movie
actually yeah she probably was she's in
a way better than that Karl the
Terminator yeah yeah it's just I like
seeing Arnold Schwarzenegger back and
again I liked him being a terminator
again but it's something I don't know
like I'm kind of ambivalent about that
was a watered down terminus well it
almost seems like they wanted him to be
like he's a serious character but he got
like all the comic relief lines yeah and
some of them were funny but then like
some of it I was kind of
they probably could have left that out
yeah he's got a personal life and he
hangs drapes he stays it's kind of funny
but it's also they basically emasculated
the [ __ ] that you know do you know why
they made him like a drapery guy it's
because like Arnold Schwarzenegger in
real life is like super energy a funny
thing to add to this like he's a drink
well he's a kind of creative guy yeah
you know so I thought that was kind of
funny at it yeah but no I just
Terminator is in the same is having the
same trouble as as predator yeah there's
only so much you can do with that and
like you said something like that
particularly sci-fi right um you know as
we get closer like I said to the actual
technology or you like that and I feel
like so I feel like it's not as special
or not as cool and you have to like lose
a lot of the mystery the more you
explain the story the more you expand
the mythology when you're talking about
predator man it's predator 1 that's a
damn masterpiece acting just the tone of
the movie the score the way it's shot
that's [ __ ] predator and it's a very
simple elemental story that had a lot of
deep underlying messages about there's
always a bigger fish very warrior
culture related and it's you know
soldiers that wrote that script that got
guys to make that movie yeah when you
start expanding it and moving it outside
of the jungle it's not it starts to
suffer because what make what made the
predator story so good was the
simplicity and the purity of it now that
one predators where they go to the
hunting planet yeah that was pretty
close to predator I like that I actually
liked that one that was easily the best
of all the yeah I think so too
now some people say the guy that the the
the main character of the story some
didn't like he was doing the Batman
voice I'm forgiving of all that kind of
[ __ ] really yeah
you know I thought it I thought
everybody did a good job and I've
watched that movie multiple times and it
stands up yeah and it's a really there's
some really for me predator and
predators are the main yeah which like I
said it's the same thing with Terminator
who's gonna say it's the same thing with
[ __ ] Nightmare on Elm Street first
one fantastic
second one terrible third one pretty
good rest of them not so good and you
know Wes Craven's new nightmare is
actually pretty decent but you know what
alien versus Predator 1 & 2 a lot of
people bag on those movies I liked him
the first one I saw the first one in the
theater and I remember liking it
well the pyramid underneath the ground
and then I don't remember a lot about it
but they were just it's because they
didn't explain much which they that's
doing the right thing yeah they just
showed his new situation and you know I
mean either they showed a little bit of
the homeworlds and it was just enough to
keep the mystery going you know no man
and even alien vs. predator 2 which is
super low budget I have fun with it it
was dark you couldn't see much but hey
yeah that was to hide the fact that the
effects were shitty but hey we got
another movie yeah I know yeah that's
right I don't know I don't think is
gonna be too many more terminators well
I don't think like I said they were
thinking about doing another trilogy but
I don't think they've at this point
since this one was you know was
disappointing so they they didn't do you
just not gonna be able to take this
story anywhere oh just not gonna be able
to take this story anywhere we yeah I
think it without shoot yourself in the
dick and that's what this that's what
this will do yeah and like I said that
that happens with any long-standing
franchise it's like there's only so many
directions you can go and still come up
with something fresh and still have an
elements of stuff that people liked from
they made vine egg they've made five
sequels and they've all kind of gone in
directions that were a little bit wonky
yes to was the least wonky
yeah but the other ones were pretty kind
of wonky yeah I'm gonna say probably I
mean I think yeah obviously the first
Terminator is the best one the second
one's the second best one this one's
probably the third best one and then
salvation is probably the fourth one and
then the other two are yeah I don't even
remember
that [ __ ] though I just watched [ __ ]
t1 predator one my predator 3 alien vs
predator just keep it [ __ ] basic but
really predator 1 and T 1 they're
masterpieces yes leave it that and like
I said I don't think anyone would argue
yeah because that's where the concept
came from the hole with those two
stories they're very self-contained
the less you know the better the less
you know they don't eat more you don't
need more the less you know the more you
will enjoy those stores yes less is more
okay and the final movie that we saw in
the theaters this week was the new
release Ford V Ferrari accident movie
this is gonna be we should probably at
the end of the year we should each do
our top ten this is easily gonna be in
my top ten moments this year maybe even
top five movie I think so this is easily
one of the one of my favorite movies of
this year's man this this is the it's a
man story it's a very male driven story
but it's it's this is how it happened
yeah yeah hey Carol Shelby you have a
Lee Iacocca yet here before jr. in this
yeah what was his name Mike the race car
driver for his name yeah yeah he died
right it he died ten miles km miles
cameras that's right Ken Wiles died
right after you know when when l'm on
the mods but you know i don't know
should you spoil that nobody knows I
didn't know yeah that's part of it you
know he was a great race car driver but
you know it just all right well how do
we how we actually review this one it's
it's a historical documentary a tale
about I guess you say almost kind of
like Brotherhood these guys conducting
corporate warfare in in the form of dam
racing yeah all right and you know Ford
tried to buy Ferrari and Ferrari said no
and Ferrari insulted Henry Ford jr. and
it pissed Henry Ford jr. off so bad that
he wanted to race against Ferrari and
defeat Enzo Ferrari at lamothe like the
most famous car racing yeah and it's
Ferrari always won they had won like the
four previous years this way this movie
set in 1966 in case you didn't know yeah
and in other markets it's called LeMans
come on 66 here because they figured
Americans wouldn't know that's really
funny singer that's called Ford versus
for art yeah so Lee Iacocca who's played
by the same guy who
play played by the Punisher what's that
Jon Bernthal Jon Bernthal Shane on
Walking Dead yeah Shane on The Walking
Dead he plays Lee Iacocca crated you
know a huge amount of screen time now
he's [ __ ] fantastic
yeah and I lived a few years you know in
Michigan you know gonna and during my
high school air period and they got
still got friends in the in the Michigan
Detroit auto world or what's left of it
and friends that worked for Ford to
ended up being forward executives and
it's just like a funny seeing you know
the Shane Lee Iacocca was a cool dude
and he did save forward on medications
later on but this this is kind of like
the earlier part of Lee Iacocca's career
before you know it he really backed
Shelby and and [ __ ] what's the guy's
name again the K miles yeah and he backs
miles and and Shelby and they make the
damn [ __ ] car you know yeah I mean
this movie it's like yeah it's called
Ford versus Burt Ferrari and that's kind
of like you know the backdrop of the
story like for trying to build a race
car that will beat Ferrari um you know
at LeMond but in between all of that
this is really a story about these two
guys friendship and also about their you
know kind of them like working toward
their dream of building the fastest car
in the world yeah
in the 1960s you know what I mean it's
because these two guys you know played
by Matt Damon and Christian Bale are
like car guys and this is their thing
and they are super super passionate
about it so it's about their friendship
it's also about like the battles that
they kind of have to go through it's
like for corporate sue - yeah all they
want is like to win they don't really
care about you know yeah you know they
don't like ten miles cuz he's difficult
and it's like they don't really want him
driving the car even though Carroll
Shelby is like oh that he's the best guy
yeah and all this is he has kind of like
this weird like spiritual thing where he
owes like everything about cars and how
to drive them and all this other kind of
stuff so they hire this British racing
team to build the Ford gt40
which was a the famous racecar this is
in the sixties race cars were still
pretty they look yeah they didn't they
don't look like [ __ ] like they wouldn't
do now to me they look ridiculous but
they still looked like the back [ __ ]
you know Chevy covers and you know
that's what they looked like that or
they look like something you could
actually own I think something you could
drive on the street yeah you know but
yeah and they show the it kind of movie
kinda reminds me of one of those
astronaut movies yeah kind of like the
right stuff it is very much like it's
very much like you remember back in the
old days when they used to have like
these kind of like historical dramas but
like a big-budget yeah with big stars
and said they don't really do that much
anymore like cuz now everything is like
has to be a franchise or comic books or
whatever so you don't see a lot of
movies like this nowadays um so it's to
me it's like amazing that it got made I
mean at this and this cost like quite a
quite a bit of money Mike I think this
it cost like a hundred million dollars
it is a must see I mean the great
[ __ ] movie you gotta say gotta see it
and you know what they're kind of like
with that remember that Apollo 11
documentary yeah yeah if reminded me of
yeah totally it felt like that you could
watch these side-by-side and their show
in California in the 60s it also kind of
felt a little bit like Quentin
Tarantino's what is a Hollywood you
notice that - yeah yeah I kind of had
that because it's taken place in that
same time period and kind of the way it
looks and feels is kind of like that I'm
not sure if it was shot on actual film
but it looked like it was you know I
mean it looked like it was shot like on
older film stock you know he's like not
in the sense that it looks shitty
because it's beautiful looking the
cinematography is beautiful the racing
scenes and stuff and I'm this is coming
from someone who's like I'm from Daytona
so I kind of know about NASCAR and [ __ ]
like that like just through osmosis
because my dad was like super into it
but you know I don't know a lot about
car racing in general but it it doesn't
matter like all of them racing scenes in
this are just like filmed awesome they
are edited awesome and they're just like
really really tense and like you know
you'll just be
like on the edge of your seat like wit
like through these whole races and stuff
like that and then there's not only that
but just all the [ __ ] character stuff
and this is so great like all this stuff
with Matt Damon and Christian Bale like
their friendship the stuff with
Christian Bale and the kid that plays
his son like the father-son stuff is
like really great all the [ __ ] like
where they're fighting with the
corporate guys and everything it's just
it's so so good and like oh them and
like interacting with their team and
trying to figure out the best way to do
this that the other thing yeah and it's
just like so [ __ ] good all the tech
heads that are [ __ ] and the guys that
turn all the wrenches that are [ __ ]
making these cars happen and we yeah and
they're trying to figure out what's
gonna happen with a gearbox and it's
cool it's like an artistic inspiration
kind of movie it doesn't matter it's
like if you don't know anything about
cars or anything like that everybody has
something like that that they can like
relate to and they don't need the
aspects between Ken miles and his wife
yeah and the money problems that they
had and that he was risking his life you
know what I mean and they had a kid and
it's it's it's cool it's an amazing
amazing movie and it's like it's funny
because when I never think about it
because Christian Bale is in so many
movies and he usually plays an American
so they actually let him because the
real Ken miles was actually from
Birmingham England and Christian Bale is
actually Welsh and I always forget that
yeah so it's like so he does actually
have a British accent think he doesn't
do a Welsh accent he actually doesn't
Birmingham accent in this movie but I
always keep forgetting that that's like
but an American isn't really how he
talks cuz we're actually not an American
you know what's interesting and I didn't
know this until I read the Wikipedia
page they've been trying to get this
movie made for like ages because I guess
a book about it came out like about this
whole I'm not sure how historically
accurate it is I read like all the
Wikipedia pages pretty close ten miles
and stuff it's like I'm sure some stuff
was dramatized but yeah it's pretty
close to what actually happened it's a
movie and certain things took longer to
do than others and you know there was
details ahead to be left out during the
development of all that you know
development of these cars you know the
gt40 you know is actually it's funny
about the gt40 it was a Ford but in the
way it was a British car you look at it
looked like a British British race car
and it was made by mostly British guys
yeah and I think it might have been
I think the prototypes was made in
England actually yeah because Ford had a
lot of money for could just buy yeah
you know they could just and you know
they bought Carroll Shelby basically
they needed him on the team and yes he
was like the best race car you feel free
he actually had won LeMond all they want
is a driver but he had to retire from
driving because he had heart condition
he had heart condition yeah so he
actually went into like building
racecars yeah and most of the movie is
about how Shelby was really rooting for
miles
yeah heat miles he knew that miles was
the guy that you needed behind the wheel
and some of the corporate kiss-asses in
Ford we're trying to get rid of miles
because he wasn't really a team player
well I want a team player and he wasn't
he was kind of chavvy you know and
they're afraid he was gonna say
something [ __ ] up yeah or because he
would speaking speak but it was on his
mind you know he was the kind of guy who
say ah [ __ ] Ford yeah he was actually
that kind of guy yeah because he was
just he only cared about racing but I
really like to really love the story I
thought the [ __ ] movie was a
masterpiece this is how you tell a story
like this all the acting was great the
casting for the [ __ ] thing was
spot-on I was just gonna mention a
stingless I didn't know until but like I
said they've been trying to get this
movie made for like a really long time
if I didn't mention it James mangle
directed this he most recently did Logan
which also got like really really huge
accolades and he's done like Girl
Interrupted needed some other really
cool [ __ ] too but as long as this has
been trying to get made and like kind of
going from hand to hand a director -
director you know who they initially
wanted to play those two parts was
[ __ ] Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt I don't
think that would have worked back in the
day like when when were you talking
about well only like a few years ago
without like ages ago in real life maybe
the last like four or five years I think
miles is about 45 46 and he was doing
LeMans for the 40s so mid to late 40s
they'd have to be around that age during
that time they could do it Coop's as
cruise was gonna play who I'm not sure
which one was gonna play wit I guess
he's gonna probably a Carroll Shelby
maybe he seems more like that then yeah
then the Ken Miles character I don't
know if it'll work there because the
thing about Christian Bale and about
Matt Damon is that they're humongous
stars but they're not tight casting
they're not tight cast and when they're
in a movie you can still forget that
it's them because like when I was
watching Christian Bale I didn't think
like oh there's Christian Bale I was
thinking oh it's Ken miles listen he
really like disappears on a roll when
Tom's in a movie that's [ __ ] time
that's what I mean and I place himself
that's what I that's the problem that I
would have thought Brad Pitt probably
would have been fine um but you know
it's I could see Brad Pitt Moore playing
Ken miles he probably could have pulled
that off um but I don't think I would
have liked Tom Cruise as the Matt Damon
character I just don't think it would've
worked cuz like you said you would've
been the whole time you'd been like oh
it's Tom Cruise huh you know what I mean
yeah this blows Days of Thunder out of
the [ __ ] water though member the Days
of Thunder film business this is one of
the best race car movies I've seen and
like I said you don't even really need
to know anything about cars or car
racing or anything like that it's just
the characters are so great you know the
story is really riveting um you really
give a [ __ ] about the characters about
what happens to them you want them to
succeed you're like route and form and
stuff yeah though the racing scenes are
almost like something out of Mad Max
they oh sure they're amazing they don't
show you anything boring they're showing
you just the wrecks and certain [ __ ]
turns if a guy's had problems on and you
know it dude couldn't shut the door
during the race all kinds of stuff and
it makes you feel like you're in the
race again some of the times especially
if you see it like in a really big
screen this is something that needs to
be seen on a big screen I feel like um
you know just because the editing and
the end the car racing scenes are so
overwhelming also the sound design is
really it's a long movie but it's yeah
along it's two hours and 32 minutes but
I was not bored for singles all right it
I I just thought this was like I put
this one up there with uh like I said
once a client time you know again I put
it once upon time and Holly would have
put it up there with that I put it up
there with Apollo 11 yeah that
documentary that documentary of the
[ __ ] space shall I put it up there
with the right stuff probably better
than the right stuff I don't like it
yeah I like this better than the right
stuff but but they are very similar like
you know dollar tone yeah yeah it feels
like a movie of the sixties actually it
does that's what I was gonna say it's
just you don't see like a lot of movies
made like you know May
like this anymore it's gritty it's
gritty but um you know where you just
have these big like this is a big like
big-budget movie but with like all these
big stars and stuff but it tells like
kind of maybe a story that a lot of
people I'm not gonna say a lot of people
can't relate to because everybody can
relate to this story in broad strokes
but it's a male dominated cast it is
they're all male characters these are
all manly men doing manly things among
other manly man --which Eve a manly
purpose but there but it's universal
struggles yeah it's something everyone
like everybody can hear so like me being
like an you know an artistic person I
can understand like knowing the
technical way of doing something and
knowing the artistic way of doing
something and having like people that
don't know anything about that like you
know money people or whatever like
trying to tell you to do this and that
you know that shit's [ __ ] up so
everybody can relate so whole separate
angle is spot-on yeah they called Ford
that's the way Ford was yeah I have
friends who have Ford executives friends
whose dads were Ford executives that's
where they were yeah yeah so like I said
this is even if you don't know anything
about car racing I think this is a very
relatable story for everybody and the
characters are so good that you get
really really invested in their fates
and stuff so definitely and I like I
said I can't see this not being in my
top movies of the year oh yeah this was
one of my favorite yeah easily so
definitely recommend it and check it out
on the big screen because it's it was as
good as dolomite yeah and dolomite was
pretty cool totally different kind of
movie totally different but I'd put this
up there with dole I'm diggin all these
kind of like retro yeah let's go back to
the past yeah like I said it's I can see
why they do it with horror movies and
stuff cuz it's like easier to make a
horror movie when nobody has nobody has
cell phones and stuff you guys haven't
heard me recommended or hurt us
recommend it before go on Netflix go
watch the Dolomites is my name yeah
Bieber Bieber you did a week or two ago
Eddie Murphy and Wesley Snipes make a
huge comeback in that flick yeah and
that
he's [ __ ] hilarious but yeah so we've
seen some like really good movies
recently wait for coming to America part
two
yeah they're both gonna be signing they
say it's gonna be great yeah yeah but
yeah so definitely Ford V Ferrari or if
it's called LeMond 66 word whatever
country you were in definitely go see
this [ __ ] on the big screen it's amazing
and hopefully get some Oscar nods win
that yeah it'll win I think I think
it'll definitely at least get nominated
for sure
I think it'll win some stuff yeah I
think it probably will do
[Music]